one in three shareholders yeah I voted
against you have they got a point yes I
agree they've got a point
the events are taking pass and the last
shall we call it three months
can't be very comfortable for them
you've got a 600 million Belgium tax
investigation
you've got accountants not seeking
re-election that's best that's a little
bit too much for most shareholders to
take the fact I can sit here and say we
don't believe the tax investigation will
be material I can't guarantee it because
I genuinely would didn't think it was an
issue before so and I don't know of any
issues yet that are making that material
as I sit here today and if I did I'd
tell you you then come on to the
accountants thing the accounts are think
obviously that red flags but I can tell
you those accounts are great I'm trying
to seek the top four accountant for the
reason to show that there is nothing to
hide I have nothing to hide why would I
fiddle myself
absolutely not go no but when the the
new accounting sort of world we're in
and people are getting under scrutiny
Sports Direct creates a lot of attention
a lot of noise I understand that's
because of the sixty percent shareholder
but they should be queuing up to know
big audiences so now I've got a company
like no no absolutely not why would they
want the Condors groups need that I
bring absolutely not and by the way
let's challenge them if you're not
afraid in the scrutiny come and do it
come and do it because what you're not
you will not bothered about my numbers
your mother about the attention that
comes with me you're worried about this
fruits me for your other clients you're
not worried about this proved to me for
me you make light of it but you might
have the Secretary of State having to
impose an accountant on you in a week I
mean that is not comfortable is it by
the way if it turned out to be a good
thing and and the Secretary of State did
a top four I was still welcoming good
and let's see if all the other people
that you audit are the same standards we
are conservative consistent and simple
let's see if they that under evidence
do you think Debenhams would have been
able to write off 600 million off their
balance sheet Sports Direct will not be
in a position here ask the right 600
million off because it would have
already done it so I see the challenge
again to the top four let's see why not
just do it for a year why not
why don't you rotate it one year for
each of you I don't care if I pay two
million in fees
why don't you regulate one after another
after another I understand the Lloyds
can't do it because there are tax
advisers and those conflicts and rules
but what about the other stream why not
as a challenge to the auditors what
about so the those who represent smaller
pension funds local authorities you know
local authority pensions are not happy
today the representative say ordinary
people who might be losing money and are
not happy about the governance what
would you say so the governance is a
very it's a very tricky thing so I think
Richard Bottomly OBE is a top top top
not exactly
I I do not accept I didn't know him
before he came as a little exec on the
SD Board I actually don't think I don't
know any but one other or two of their
non execs on SD what will happen is that
I get the bit of the media I'm not being
rude frenzy around the mark Pesce
Football Club owning its media guys it's
Pento villains fine please it's not the
real world and that extra media allows
people to us if you like sometimes throw
stones that aren't justified and I'm
quite happy I can't do more than welcome
to top four Auditor
what about the guy today his name was
John Gray
why doesn't he come on let's say as we
already found 10 Clarke earlier in a
different interview saying why does he
come on as a full-blown non-exec why
doesn't John Gray come on over the
deserve
why doesn't he join sports tourettes
non-exec
board as an observer if you think it's
so wrong come and sit there but you have
to stand up for Sports Direct when you
realize that Sports Direct is just a
painter villain
stop it
I love a question people have is about
the overall strategy everyone else is
running from the high street young
buying up distressed brands or one more
as if there's one so distressed you
wouldn't see is an opportunity yeah how
convinced are you that that's going to
work even the changes on the high street
and changing the way we shop okay so the
answer is in your question it's the way
we shop there is no question that
retailing has changed in ten years out
of all proportion there is no doubt that
though as I call them the clicks are
destroying the bricks the bricks have to
do think different they have to be the
brandy partners and show elevation in
the high street that the brands that
they represent one end somehow double up
for what customers want on the high
street you've got to join those two
together that's where the opportunity is
I believe and I could be wrong that we
are absolutely well on the way to be in
the first sizable company to do that I
think as I said if you've got a lesser
if you're in here you're seeing this
elevation strategy work and the best one
of the best examples of that is JD
elevation is working we're gonna do it
bigger and better than them simple as
that you mentioned a panto villain and
you play up to it a little perhaps
sometimes although I think some of this
you down to your personal style okay
you're gonna change no no don't one
thing from when I floated everybody knew
I'd does exactly what it says on the tin
so why would I change I'm not
necessarily wrong compare me to
debenhams with all the guns all the
board all the structure all everything
and where do they end up shareholders
zero we're still going we're still in
the fight it might be the Bachmann
eleventh I Marta picking myself off the
canvas twice but I think I'm gonna win
on points and I believe that you're you
it's a listing company now but you're
still running it in the same way you did
when you were one store that's not true
no no I wish it was as easy as one store
and I wish I probably could actually
know everything that's going on in the
company Sports Direct across the
different fascias countries everything
else is enormous I can honestly tell
people I had nothing to do with buying
this building I have nothing to do
flannels elev I asked very little to do
with the SD elevation but somehow
because it's a shareholder that's sixty
percent everybody thinks I know
everything it's simply impossible and
just so we're clear I don't pick the
Newcastle team and I never add because
that gets thrown at me as well if you're
me that's where you get this okay guys
paint Overland just let's just take that
down a notch if that's okay